when talking with the ceos with the
founders i'm asking them to check uh on
everybody and see that everybody's okay
uh trying to uh to have those weeklies
start with the understanding that
everybody or if somebody needs something
uh we should be very tentative we should
always ask them we should not be in
those in that place that you are
he's not saying nothing it means that
everything is okay he's not saying
because he doesn't know
what he can what we but he can get out
of it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opus labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello everyone and welcome to 20 minute
leaders this episode is all about talent
and hr and recruitment meet dana bash
chela
dana is the ceo of italian a leader in
the tech recruitment field they are
committed to leaving organizations and
their people in a truly better place
more changeable more engaged and better
equipped for creating a better future
[Music]
i'm really excited to to talk to you
about
this thing that we call talent and
recruitment which at the end obviously
feeds into what everybody agrees is the
most important aspect of a team which is
the team members right you know they
have the product you have the the
capital you have the strategy but then
it's all the team members that make it
and um you have a very unique
perspective as the ceo of italian
looking at this a little bit from a
higher perspective seeing the different
recruitment patterns and organizations
what works what doesn't work and more
interestingly the strategy that um some
leaders have to employ when they're
thinking about their upcoming hires or
the recruitment needs in general so a
lot to unpack i apologize already that
i'm going to take you quickly into into
this field but but dana tell me a little
bit about eye talent and how you got
into this talent recruitment process
okay so when i've been working in the
equipment industry for the last two
decades
uh before founding italian my last place
award was mercury a company which was
acquired by hp
i was leading the sourcing efforts for
hp and israel and i learned a lot about
the
the final and the recruitment and i i
had a lot of
a lot of time to think about candidates
and what they like what what's important
for them
and when i founded italian 12 years ago
it was under the understanding and the
understanding that
there is a huge gap that should be
reached and there's the
the usual channels are were not enough
let's say a advanced work with a lot of
hr agencies
and the what i found working in an
organization is that the return on
investment is very low because
their interest is give brilliantly
as many people as as possible
and one will sign and this was not my
interest as a company my interest
interest was getting the best people the
best qualified people and
that was the reason i founded ital and
today i taunted
is a
is the biggest rpo company rpos
it's a recruitment process a management
we are a company that manages the whole
recruitment cycle for our companies
ninety percent of our companies are
startups they mostly
after their seed or round a today it's
like a seed round a is
almost the same and we also work with
corporates us corporates all over the
world
uh we have uh the rpo is the biggest
unit we also have the
executive leadership group which handles
a recruitment of ceo and sea levels
and we have a global unit which handles
the familiar worldwide mainly the us
market and europe
and the fourth
unit is the academy we teach
organization how to recruit
we have uh
for example
let's talk about companies like crap
by the way i just want to make sure that
that i understand because you're you're
you're i'm hearing things you're hearing
your ma you know
the the management of the recruitment
process but then you're also saying you
know on the educational front you're
also enabling and catalyzing existing
leadership to know how to recruit so how
do you well you know these are two
different offerings right one is taking
care of of the process one is actually
empowering the existing team to do it
well what are the differences there's
there are companies that know that
when you have a
recruitment plan they usually put with
blend sometimes you will hire people to
do that in homes sometimes you know that
the hiring process will take a uh let's
say let's talk about four or two so at
those cases you don't have to
necessarily have to have those people on
board you will use a company like hours
so
i believe you that the companies that
need our services can use us for civil
and we want we would like to be a
one-stop shop for all their
equipment needs and sometimes when they
grow in the skills let's talk about
companies such as rapid papi is one of
our clients they hired about 12 new
recruiters and all they know how all the
training was done by italian
uh we're working with the recruitment
team working with recruitment managers
and there is a lot of work today uh with
the the hiring managers uh we're talking
a lot about uh we we're talking a lot
about your digital persona
uh you know
10 years ago you didn't have to be
upfront over there you didn't have to
to own your linkedin profile today you
are handling
very
various uh
places which you should because people
are looking at you hey people uh when
people are
coming to see you they they need the
information and they finally they found
it they find it through google and then
they go to the social media site or
other way and they were seeing any
conventions where it was
we wouldn't still met people
and uh
that knowledge gives you a a
strong plus
a while
while you are meeting those people later
on in your uh during your recruitment
process
um
and so at the end if you're looking at
the the knowledge for a minute about you
know the the
the right process to go about this
um you know previously i imagined that
you know recruitment was mainly about
putting an ad on the newspaper for an
open job uh having people walk in to the
interviews having one or two interviews
and then announcing the position today
it's a little bit different right the
way the engagement levels the
the the trying to the different things
that you're trying to match before you
actually provide an offer what what are
what what are the gaps that have formed
between those that understand how to do
it properly
uh you know
through for example the educational
platforms of talent or the processes
that you're managing yourself versus
those that are coming in and saying you
know what i'm just going to do this old
school and and this is how i'm thinking
what are sort of the things that
the whole school doesn't work
you you you you just chartered the the
this and you said something like he
would they put in your head and somebody
will reach out to that okay so
the israeli market
it's like a roller coaster during the
last two and a half years
it was uh first of all it's the at the
the coronal time it was it covered the
time at the beginning everybody stayed
a foot and selling their own companies
because they didn't know what's gonna
happen that was the ignition start so
right at this stage it was like
what am i waiting for nothing will
happen if i'm i'm not going to be
proactive if i'm not going to have the
proactive approach and i will not reach
out to those people they will not come
so
the companies had to change
when you're thinking about a recruitment
to you you're thinking about something
that
uh there you have we had the those ats
applicant tracking system and i'm saying
what is applicant
he doesn't know that he's an applicant
we are reaching out to somebody who's
probably working who's probably uh
should he is usually in a good place why
should he come
and do something and then and start the
other process so you have to find your
egb employee valid proposition
this is the the most important thing for
every company when
even even the founding team where
they're one or two founders and they're
thinking about what's the their next
stage i'm saying to them this is the
time to start you to the into think
about your adp
why is it so important your evp right
can change
but you have to find it because to each
a candidate your evp can be different
let's say you let's let's say you talk
about the healthcare field many
companies in the healthcare field have a
great advantage because people want to
be meaningful
and if you if you say that say that loud
say that when we didn't come here when
you're gonna come a whoop for us you're
gonna impact your glass
it's very very appealing to all ages
it's very appealing to the young people
which we always say they're going only
for the money no no no people want to be
meaningful so
evp is something that you must have as a
company
and then you when you have the evp
you have to understand
that the world has changing you don't
only look for somebody who has one two
three
if we if we can um the only thing that
i'm i'm saying if you cannot
replicate dolly
and make those engineers replicate
themselves it would be great but this is
not the situation it's a very
competitive market
and uh in
each and every time we're having those
conversations we are we are minus 10 000
engineers in the israeli industry only
here all the time 10 000 positions that
are not filled and why should it come to
us so and then then we talk about the
process the processes are really changed
with the the became virtual
whenever you met somebody and it wasn't
online there was a sort of commitment
you know i'm seeing you there is a
commitment you came i've asked you how
was the weather if it's well it was okay
my office is there and there was a
commitment in
our our communication
communicating with candidates and during
those that period we really changed and
we had to show them something that we
don't we don't we we don't really at all
we can show them but a lot of companies
have adjusted
for example a new tech company like um i
really like those guys in drive-ness
they have a pair in their recruitment
manager is called cigar and what she did
uh you can come to the office you will
not see the office you will work for you
from home but we wanted you we want you
to see the office so somebody took a
camera home took his phone
and he filmed the the the room and the
work environment and whatever they have
here
it was all uh
to give you the notion of the feeling
that you are you are there
by connecting in another ways uh
processes became really short
and there is no time it seems like
during the last year the the last year
to 2021
we are talking about the 30 percent
raise in the in the israeli server
salary of the
of let's talk about senior engineers
okay i'm not even talking about senior
aor executives
somebody was three to five uh
these were the most wanted talents
so
numbers
the numbers are something that the the
will say that media really likes to talk
about
they always they ask me how much the
numbers have been raised and what's the
differences
but the real story is that everybody
will be aligned at the end
everybody will be at the same numbers so
when you're choosing your latest
adventure sure and it more and more
things like like choosing an adventure
your evp is the most important thing in
the process you combine i call it you
can buy the property
the the pump
which is finding those people and then
engaging them into the process making it
really short
and um
i think
our uh success really comes from there
if we're looking
for a moment at the expectation from
both ends so we're talking a lot about
the change of expectations between
the uh the candidates the applicants the
you know the avp that now recruiters
have to take into account the different
experiences they have to
to shine and the fact that you're what
you're mentioning is that the parameters
for a company to for for an applicant to
choose on their side the company
there's a lot of parameters now right
it's no longer just the salary or just
the benefits it's now the meaning it's
now the culture it's the people it's the
different opportunities
so one of the things that there is sort
of this new aligned expectation is also
the time frame in which a candidate
agrees to join a company for right if
before there was an expectation of a
candidate staying for a long time now
candidates are saying wait i'm not i'm
not sure i'm ready to commit right now
for five years ahead let's start with
one or two years on a cultural
expectation
what's happening there and is this
something that is
you know that is valid in in today's
world
hey two and a half years ago i was just
before corona i was invited by linkedin
to
a convention called talent connected
london
and i was listening to a very
fascinating lecture held by um
she was the the vpn of tesco which is
the biggest retailer
in britain and she says
she said that our children are going to
their work
it's 50 50 not 50
50 different workplaces she talked a lot
about geek economy
and she she she and she
and and then there and then it was got
it was like
mind-blowing for me to understand that
uh it really makes it difficult for
companies uh
and because the changes it's like it's
not a change the swift we're looking
into one any one and one and a half year
people who work in different places
they're all together and it's
it's very it's changing the world but it
makes a lot of um
interesting
things
it challenges the company
the companies to change
and to understand that this is reality
and they walk in load about how to to to
keep those people with the company but
they it it became something that is
parallel that you can understand so
i can say that we are seeing that not
only when we we're talking about the the
engineering level
it's very common but
during last year we also saw that
happening
in
in the management and we saw a lot of
management uh changes
we had a lot of uh swift because
it happens because the companies are now
scanning up right and the forming
management is no longer relevant for the
new challenges so you see a lot of
changes both
in the
in the in the engineering but not only
there yeah i think um
it's not that we given up on
keeping our people and making them happy
where they work
but we understand this is part of the
game
and there's
um
it takes me to another place thank you
for the
it seems like there are a lot of
transactions let's let's talk about the
equipment market
and look at it as if it's another market
he said well if if 10 years ago the
transaction happened
after three or four years
while you work we were working in your
company today it happens after one year
or whatever one year and a half
the the interesting thing about it is is
that it gives a lot of hr take and
recruitment i think
uh very interesting platforms because if
the transactions are
which which were rare and
didn't know five years ago and now they
happen so uh
uh
it happened very very fast there is a
new market for aj attack and i must say
for us okay for example
this made a lot of
a
digital transfer quest and
transformation we just opened our own
company called candy which is still from
the at this stage but it was it was all
about
interacting with canada through ai
parts and other stuff i think it will
take our field to another level because
when we reached when i i'm
one of the first people to use linkedin
i'm buying myself uh
it was like in 2004 and i was i remember
in my first interaction with candy they
they were like what you are interacting
with me they it was it was very amazing
and during the during the last
10 and 15 years it changed imagine
yourself being blown up in a daily basis
by recruiters
all are saying we have wonderful
opportunities you have to listen to them
so this is this is the i'm not saying
that linkedin is there and i'm saying
that
the the first is the only only
understanding that
your client is uh
he needs another way to reach out to so
you use a lot of technology
and for us it was a great change great
change because
when i
founded the company 10 years ago i was
but i i was able to to reach out to 40
people
and the final was like this uh
said okay let's hear today we are
talking about
many more rituals we're talking about
thousands of reach outs
no and i think that um what you're
touching on is a very interesting trend
that we're seeing and you're talking now
about there are different opportunities
and and i'm also going back to what the
head of hr tesco said about the gig
economy and and understanding you know
how much
when is culture important when is the
relationship truly important and and the
flexibility of knowing that there's this
person that may be a great
fit for the company maybe they're not
ready to commit to a family but maybe
they're ready to contribute to a company
to contribute to a mission
and we still yeah we stopped using the
the word family
i think i think
i think we're not where
we used to be especially in the israeli
market we used to combine between those
things and yeah and i think
especially during quranic time coffee
time people understood that
there is the family and there is my job
but as you say here i i don't think the
importance for
a of the
i think the thing is that yeah when you
feel that you're part of a great thing
and this is something every management
uh should look into and they explore all
the time
is
to be meaningful and when you you make
me when you and
emphasizing this and in warming you you
don't only say that or rented in the
world you know what you know whenever
you're going to a company the worlds are
full of
very nice things people say about
themselves but the thing is how the
managers on the daily basis especially
when they're working from far not not
seeing their people on a daily basis
do a good job managing
i think management
became really tough
i think many people today everybody
wants to be a manager but when they're
where they're in that position today
they their challenges are huge
and it's mainly composed of uh maybe i
will i will talk about
maybe about the emotional emotional
management we're talking a lot about
managing emotions
uh
10 years ago when you manage those
engineering teams everybody was
everybody has had it
start today whenever every company works
in an agile you're really dependent on
your team and the the manager is the one
who
conducts this so we're talking about
using understanding
the the the place or the the
walking alone talking a lot about
feelings
starting the day with the
how are you feeling are you okay
understand
we're we're we're entering people's
lives you know we're talking with them
and they're talking from from their own
they they have one child in the house in
one side and the other one is screaming
and you should be very attentive to that
and very a and listen
we were talking a lot about listening
and trust translating emotions talking
about that
and um this is highly important i think
that
it comes from the
team leaders are
mainly the subject of
the
of those uh
new um
mandatory thing but i think when
when talking with the ceos with the
founders i'm asking them to check uh on
everybody and see that everybody is okay
uh trying to uh to have those weeklies
start with the understanding that
everybody or if somebody needs something
uh we should be very tentative we should
always ask them we should not be in
those in that place that you are
he's not saying nothing it means that
everything is okay he's not saying
because he doesn't know
what he can what we but he can get out
of because for us for everybody it's a
new it's a new stage
uh yeah let's talk companies who became
hybrid
they're most of the companies in israel
are in hybrid states most of them work
two to three days in the office
uh this really helped managers
uh um gather their teams around them
uh come
most of the market is working in that
way and i think it's here for here to
stay i think it's here to stay
i think that there's
so many things that that were opening up
you know and and i love the conversation
about the emotional management and
and that's obviously you know it's
becoming even more complicated and um
when we're looking at the gig economy
and what is our role as managers and
what happens when we have team members
that are
some of them are part-time some of them
are full-time some of them are
contractors some of them are really do
spend most of their time here some of
them are balancing and how do you create
an environment where where you fee where
they feel like you're like you're
committed to them regardless and
obviously hybrid work and so we we have
we have a lot more to unpack but
unfortunately i called the show 20
minute leaders and i need to to abide by
that and dana thank you very very much
for for the time and for the for the
insights and uh and i can i am looking
forward to continue learning about
recruitment and about hr processes and
hr tech and seeing the new company candy
come to life so thank you very much best
of luck and stay safe and stay healthy
[Music]